Ohio State University offers a course called
“Sports for the Spectator.”.
Students are taught how to be “an informed
and appreciative sports spectator.”
70% of all train journeys in England start
or finish in London.
Swinging your arms when walking makes it 12%
easier.
Travelling at normal speed, it takes a fully
loaded supertanker 20 minutes to stop.
They usually cut their engines 15 miles away
from the dock.
Research shows that plants grow better when
they're stroked.
The record number of live goldfish swallowed
at a single sitting is 210.
Frank Sinatra took a shower 12 times a day.
Before the invention of electricity, human
beings slept for 90 minutes longer than they
do now.
The fastest swallow in nature is that of the
frogfish, which sucks its prey down in 0.006
seconds.
At it's peak Blockbuster Video earned nearly
$800 million through late fees alone, making
up 16% of its revenue.
The first baseball caps were made of straw.
The ancient Egyptians mummified beef ribs,
sliced duck and goat meat to eat in the afterlife.
Mozart's sister was also a musician, who sometimes
took top billing as they toured Europe together.
The most leaves ever found on a clover is
12.
Statically, too much homework can cause depression
and lower grades.
Getting angry at people when listening to
them breathing or eating is an actual neurological
disorder called Misophonia.